en tant que programmeur rencontrer le
PDG, je veux un concours que le président
ne peut pas obtenir mr.  Garrick au téléphone tu
as le billet d'or c'est bon de te rencontrer
Nathan ça va te rencontrer aussi
peut-on juste dépasser tout le
truc employeur-employé À votre santé à bien des
égards ce bâtiment n'est pas une maison c'est un
centre de recherche Je veux  vous
parler du plus grand événement scientifique de
l'histoire de l'homme êtes-vous en train de construire une
IA bonjour salut jamais rencontré quelqu'un de nouveau
avant vous n'en avez pas comme vous
elle est incroyable le défi est de
vous montrer qu'elle est un robot et ensuite de voir
si vous la sentez toujours  a conscience
veux-tu être mon ami bien sûr
sera-t-il possible pourquoi ne serais-
tu jamais sorti de ce bâtiment nous
pourrions aller ensemble l'as-tu programmée pour
flirter avec moi
penses-tu à moi si tu mens je
ne le ferai pas non  salut
peut-être qu'elle fait semblant de t'aimer bien
pourquoi ferais-tu ça penses-tu que je
pourrais être éteint ce n'est pas à moi
pourquoi est-ce à quelqu'un tu ne devrais pas
faire confiance à Nathan tu ne devrais pas faire confiance à
tout ce qu'il dit Je pense que c'est le  prochain
modèle c'est parti  nna être la vraie
percée qu'est-ce que tu fais l'
ancien tu dois m'aider un jour il y a
tu peux regarder en arrière sur nous des singes debout tous
prêts pour l'extinction
c'est étrange d'avoir fait quelque chose qui
te déteste
que faisais-tu avec Ava